anastasia euro va vient d'arriver dans
l'ouest du kosovo pour se former au
déminage cette jeune ukrainienne viens
d'une région pilonnées par l'armée russe
pour cet humanitaire de 25 ans apprendre
à déminer est une façon de résister à la
violence de la guerre
énormément de terres agricoles sont
aujourd'hui contaminés par les engins
explosifs à cause des hostilités
mais c'est aussi le cas dans de
nombreuses grandes villes et d'autres
localités
c'est pour ça que c'est important ce
qu'on fait car à notre retour en ukraine
on pourra se servir de ce qu'on a appris
il y a vingt ans les instructeurs
kosovar eux aussi ont connu la guerre et
les terrains minés un conflit qui a
coûté la vie à plus de 13 mille
personnes
oui
dans ce court on focalise sur les types
d'explosifs qu'ils vont trouver en
ukraine ce que les russes utilisent
contre les ukrainiens
et on leur apporte notre expérience de
la guerre des balkans lorsque c'était
l'ex yougoslavie qui fabriquait les
armes des armes qui sont comparables à
celles utilisées par les russes
aujourd'hui
mais pour anastasia la formation ne se
limite pas à un enseignement technique
ici elle se sent comprises
quand ça va en sort le kosovo a aussi
vécu la guerre et eux aussi ont lutté
pour leur indépendance est ici les gens
peuvent vraiment entendre ce que l'on
ressent et ce par quoi on passe
après 4 semaines de formation intensive
anastasia yeoh rova rentrera chez elle
pour un travail à long terme selon les
experts des mines est le territoire
ukrainien pourrait prendre des décennies